to begin with our problem statement
cystic fibrosis is an autosomal
recessive disease which negatively
impacts multiple organs in the body
resulting in a high mortality rate by
understanding the specific gene mutation
and carriers of the disease we can
identify potential Therapeutics to
prevent the passing of the mutation to
offspring saving countless lives every
year first what is cystic fibrosis
cystic fibrosis is a Progressive genetic
disease that causes persistent lung
infections and limits the ability to
breathe over time cystic fibrosis is
also life-threatening and people with
the condition tend to have a shorter
than normal lifespan